on son château en ecosse le prince harry
et sa femme et gagnent sont également en
route vers l'ecosse le royaume uni est
littéralement suspendu à l'état de santé
de sa souveraine on va en parler dans ce
débat assez longuement avec mes invités
j'ai le plaisir d'avoir mes côtés
philippe talleu notre chroniqueur
internationale sur france24 bonsoir
philippe merci d'être avec nous jeremy à
stubbs bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
directeur adjoint de la rédaction de
causeur vous êtes également président de
l'association des conservateurs
britanniques de paris bienvenue à vous
nous avons hervé amaury qu'à londres un
autre correspondant qui va être avec
nous à tout au long de cette émission re
bonsoir hervé et puis kevin guyot qui
est avec nous historiens fondateur du
site la monarchie britannique point com
bonsoir à vous et merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous ce soir nous avons aussi marc
skype de londres agnès poirier
journaliste correspondante de l'express
à londres bonsoir à vous agnès poirier
bienvenue également bonsoir
ça a été annoncé il ya peu près deux
heures les médecins dont qui se disent
préoccupés par la santé de la reine
elizabeth 2 2 puis bien sûr une foule
commence à se rassembler devant
buckingham palace on va écouter d'abord
quelques réactions
elle est là depuis que je suis en vie
depuis que mes parents sont en vie donc
elle est vraiment une partie très
importante de la société vous savez ça
va être terrible si elle meurt
il y a deux jours elle était avec la
nouvelle première ministre et maintenant
d'un coup tout le monde s'inquiète pour
elle c'est triste mais god save the
queen
ils sont aussi selon hervé amauri qui y
est donc un jeu le disait notre
correspondant hervé la foule s'amasse un
peu plus chaque minute j'imagine
absolument on les voit de plus en plus
désormais il dépasse on voit des gens
des deux côtés du monument tout à
l'heure il y avait un seul côté du
monument on voyait une une marais de
parapluies mais maintenant ils le public
le moins et effectivement il ya des gens
un peu partout ceux qui ont peut
s'attendre à ce que cette place est tout
le mal ici qui descend jusque presque
jusqu'au au parlement là bas soit noire
de monde bientôt c'était le cas à
l'époque du duo moment du jubilé de la
célébration des 70 ans de règne
d'elizabeth ii lorsque la population est
venue dire adieu au monarque dont
elizabeth ii dans son rôle officiel au
balcon de buckingham palace toute sa
famille étaient rassemblés comme elle
l'est aujourd'hui ses enfants ses
petits-enfants par mieux bien sûr
plusieurs héritiers de la couronne le
prince charles son fils william et même
les petits enfants qui étaient les
enfants de william qui étaient là
derrière elle et qui ont assisté aux
cérémonies donc c'était un moment un
moment
qui était un
des symboles des moments symboliques de
son règne effectivement les gens qui
sont ici ce soir savent que bientôt ils
pourront rendre hommage à la reine et du
rhin adieux à la reine la personne la
femme effectivement la fin de deux dents
longues règne s'approche tout le monde
ici autour de nous tous les britanniques
ou presque tous donc connu qu elisabeth
2 comme rennes comme symbole de l'unité
de ce pays malgré toutes les divisions
malgré le break site qui a fracturé la
société malgré
les divisions politiques lors de
l'annoncé de liste run 1 qui a formé un
gouvernement très à droite évidemment
côté travailliste toute une partie de la
population rejette une partie de cette
pensée politique mais à partir de cet
après midi les britanniques sont
unis on ne parle plus du plan
énergétique de liste reçue on ne
s'inquiète presque plus de comment on va
payer ses factures de gaz ou
d'électricité
effectivement les gens sont inquiets et
pense à la fin de dernière heure au
dernier jour de leur souverain
philippe philip earl vous êtes franco
britannique lorsque les médecins disent
qu'ils sont inquiets préoccupée par
l'état de santé de la reine qu'est ce
que ça signifie qu'elle sera la
prochaine communication à buckingham
palace ça c'est toute la question alors
pour mettre les choses dans l'ordre les
communiqués sont la santé de la reine
sont extrêmement rares la dernière fois
on a enfin eu deux ou trois mais c'est
quand même excessivement rare on a eu un
communiqué que pour lesquels à hulk au
vide et on a une communiqué pour des cas
la bdic des problèmes de mobilité donc
essais en moins en moins présentes pour
les festivités du jubilé mais on n'a pas
accès aux informations de santé de la
reine ça fait partie de la domaine privé
en grande bretagne et donc on ne peut
pas se pose la question comment la reine
et avoir la réponse donc on est un sujet
et est assujettie à la
à la merci de barquin par là ce qui va
nous distiller des informations au fur à
mesure du moment où ils pensent eux que
c'est propice pour qu'on sache comment
la reine dont on a eu cette annonce tout
à l'heure vers 13h30 heure de paris nous
indiquons que la reine était mal en
point
on n'attend pas d'autres nouvelles de la
part de ces médecins ni de la part de
banques un palace qui va nous informer
de ce qui va se passer alors que vu
l'inquiétude grandissante la foule qui
commence à se masser devant bac un
palace est aussi
et toutes les chaînes d'information
partout dans le monde qui font du
non-stop solheim je pense que la
pression monte pour que les médecins ne
nous donne quelques informations sur la
santé normalement je pense que mon avis
est que la non ce qui était fait stop
midi
et peut-être une façon de préparer le
peuple britannique à une annonce plus
grave pour ne pas les faire les choquer
avec une annonce inattendue sur le décès
de la mode du monna peu à monaco donc je
pense que c'est un premier pas pour
préparer l'opinion publique à une
annonce peut-être plus grave plus tard
pour qu'on soit pas trop choquer le
moment où cette annonce soit posté juste
pour information comment on va la
prendre si la reine est décédé c'est
toujours la même manière il y aura une
annonce qui soit affichée de vont bâcler
un palace je pense qu'on saura avant
mais officiel mentionnant une annonce
qui affichait de vos marques un palace
sont les grilles tout-petits annonce qui
va
exactement comme pau son père georges
cisson 1952 james tape ça vous êtes
d'accord est viennent dire philippe
teurs donc il devrait y avoir une
annonce écrite si effectivement on doit
apprendre ce soir dans les jours qui
viennent le décès de la reine oui tout à
fait et tout à fait ce sera fait selon
les en bonne et due forme selon la
tradition et tout cela est extrêmement
important
en même temps
l'inquiétude est tellement grandes en ce
moment que
6,6 étaient exagérées quelqu'un nous
aurait dit
calmez vous donc le fait que cela monte
sans que quoi que ce soit
nous disent tout va bien ça indique
qu'il faut s'attendre au pire donc comme
l'a dit philippe on est en nous prépare
psychologiquement pour le pire le pire
c'est-à-dire ma le décès de la reine et
ses prêts ça va venir un moment un autre
donc et puis c'est vrai que ce qu'ils un
choc et je pense beaucoup de gens et
qu'ils y compris moi même c'est que
cette semaine mardi les strass
la nouvelle première ministre
a est allé voir la reine pour
recevoir lourde de la reine d'assumer
ses fonctions et on n'avait pas vu la
reine ni photos ni d'image depuis des
semaines et des semaines et chaque fois
qu'il y avait quelque chose que la reine
devait faire c'était annulé dernière
chose en date c'était d'être présent au
jour un jeu écossais donc on si on n'a
pas de photos pas l'image de la reine
lors du passage de pouvoir on te
positionner les strauss là il ya de quoi
s'inquiéter donc on a eu cette photo qui
était un effort réponse pour calmer les
esprits le public
l'opinion publique pour des banderoles à
la reine elle est debout et là ça calme
mais c'est à la demande de l'estrie le
problème c'est que quand on voit cette
photo de la reine on la voit très
affaibli très amaigri elle a une grosse
tache sur la main droite ce qui veut
dire qu'elle a peut-être subi des
perfusions mais c'est une femme
visiblement qui est très frêle donc
alors que c'était une photo publiée pour
rassurer les gens je pense que ça
inquiète et peut-être plus que ça
marcherait n est ce pas rien vous êtes
d'accord avec l'indien philippe tort
cette photo a plutôt inquiété les gens
et on est en train de préparer ce que
disait jah mike stobbe on est en train
de préparer les britanniques est
d'ailleurs le monde entier au décès de
la reine c'est ce qui se passe en ce
moment
oui c'est une évidence et puis il faut
toujours lire entre les lignes
parce que ça en fait ça a commencé quand
on regarde on regardait les
parlementaires sur la chaîne
parlementaire ce qui était mon cas
aujourd'hui
et que tout d'un coup on a eu cette
fébrilité alors d'abord liste ross on
apprend aux parades des députés présents
à
la chambre des communes
chris brown député travailliste ed a
même tweeté à ce moment là en disant
quelque chose d'inhabituel est en train
de se passer il y à un briefing urgent
donc les strauss par ensuite elle est
suivie de qui est à ma on a pu voir
d'ailleurs des petits boss échanger sur
les bancs entre les députés l'atmosphère
était assez fébriles ils continuer comme
ça à prendre la parole à tour de rôle
pour la question du jour n'est enfin
pour les questions à l'ordre du jour
pardon
est donc déjà la fébrilité commençait et
puis ensuite on a eu ce communiqué de
buckingham palace mais faut vraiment
s'il ya beaucoup de retenue et donc du
coup c'est inquiétant parce que comme
l'a rappelé philippe on ne bat king and
palaces ne parle pas de la santé de la
reine à moins qu'il y ait quelque chose
de majeur et donc oui il ne pourrait pas
une préparation ne même que à 14h tout
d'un coup on a vu les présentateurs de
la bbc d'abord habillés en bleu marine
est maintenant au noir
saft il quelque chose que nous ne savons
pas encore c'est possible donc même si à
la seconde de la mort de la souveraine
tous depuis des années tout il y à un
protocole ou c'est exactement ce que ce
qui va se passer le moment n'est pas
encore arrivé du moins officiellement et
voilà les britanniques maintenant sap
que c'est une question probablement d'un
kevin guyot puisque vous êtes
l'historien de ce plateau c'est une
question d'heure est ce que tout vous
semble je dirais vous qui êtes
l'historien tout vous semble aller dans
ce sens-là cette préparation au décès de
la reine quoi on dirait plutôt dans les
heures qui viennent dans les jours qui
viennent
[Musique]
pense surtout à nos préoccupations
ce mot a été utilisé quelques fois par
le passé surtout lorsqu'on pense
comparant ce physique la seule fois où
ils ont utilisé ce nous c'est vraiment
lorsqu'il était à la fin de sa vie et de
son état était depuis occupants
justement donc de savoir qu'ils
utilisent ce modèle à penser que la
reine est sur le point de décider et que
les jours qu'on doit plus arriver et
comme ce peintre jours va bientôt
arriver et par rapport aux effets
l'événement passé c'est vraiment comme
ça que
c'est vraiment comme ça qu'ils ont
rivard et les britanniques dans le sens
où comme vous et philippe où le roi
george au site à sa mort on a commencé
on dit le protocole à la vie comme on va
faire aujourd'hui sûr qu'aujourd'hui on
va jouer en pointe kevin et kevin guyot
je vous interromps pardon pardonnez moi
parce qu'on a un vrai problème de sang
avec vous on va essayer de le régler ce
problème de son en attendant on va
revenir un petit peu justement sur ce
parcours de la reine qui a accédé au
trône en 1952 d'ailleurs en 1997 ce a
marqué un tournant dans la monarchie
britannique ont dit justement que eh
bien il a commencé à y avoir des
réformes alors est ce que cette
monarchie britannique s'est adapté s'est
transformée on voit tout de suite cela
en images avec caroline grandjean et
andrew est là
son image a marqué l'histoire elisabeth
deux reines de l'ère post moderne et de
ces médias sous le feu des projecteurs
elle connaît les débuts de la télévision
les tabloïds font aussi l'opinion
publique en étalant la vie des
célébrités en 1992 un incendie ravage le
château de windsor
c'est alors au contribuable que revient
la facture des réparations de la demeure
préférés de la reine
nineteen rennes
nantes
pour éviter aux britanniques de payer
les travaux de leur poche l'année
suivante la reine a une idée ouvrir le
palais de buckingham au public une
première et un succès ou indoor peut
renaître de ses cendres grâce à la vente
de billets et produits dérivés
la décennie 90 a mis à rude épreuve
l'image de la souveraine et de la
monarchie le divorce de diana et charles
le prince héritier donne lieu à un
véritable tapage médiatique rumeurs de
tromperies scandale les moindres faits
et gestes de l'ancien couple sont
scrutés un déchaînement des paparazzi
qui prend des allures de harcèlement
pour diana
la princesse diana qui avait conquis le
coeur du public reste dans les bonnes
grâces du peuple britannique en 1997 le
silence de la reine après la mort de
lady di est assourdissant
un quart des britanniques souhaitent
alors l'abolition de la monarchie
véritable tournant dans l'histoire la
famille royale doit revoir son image et
c'est un mariage qui lui en donne
l'occasion en 2011 williams le petit
fils de la reine elizabeth épouse kate
middleton une roturière
c'est l'avènement d'une nouvelle
génération princière qui se départit de
la tradition
c'était si beau et c'est vraiment
magnifique tout était somptueux toute la
famille royale c'était extraordinaire
sept ans après c'est au tour du cadet de
se marier harry épouse meghan markle une
actrice afro américaine divorcée et
offre ainsi un compte de tous les
possibles aux médias les deux couples
royaux rivalisent d'initiatives voyage
des bénévoles à soignies les relations
publiques de la famille royale opération
communication
la souveraine dévoile son côté espiègle
pour la cérémonie d'ouverture des jeux
olympiques de londres en 2012 elle
apparaît dans une vidéo au côté de
daniel craig dans le rôle de james bond
des milliards de téléspectateurs
assistent en direct à une mise en scène
stupéfiante
avant de l'avoir gagné la tribune royale
le windsor adopte désormais de nouveaux
codes et surf sur les réseaux sociaux
une façon de rendre accessible le faste
et les ors de la royauté mieux maîtriser
la communication de la couronne a bien
évolué elizabeth ii a même un compte
instagram
indiens qui sont tout de suite banking
and palaces justement on retrouve encore
hervé 1v amérique vous êtes toujours
avec nous on en est on devant buckingham
palace la foule continue à venir
et je dois me retourner et je dois dire
qu'à chaque fois que je me retourne il
ya beaucoup plus de gens
désormais ça arrive presque jusqu'à nous
il ya un périmètre de sécurité ici pour
les chaînes de télévision du monde
entier qui sont à côté de moi justement
pour pas ce qu'il ya de plus en plus de
gens et sur le mal et ses convois d une
foule de gens qui s'approche alors
effectivement maintenant les gens ont
fini de travailler sans doute est de
plus en plus de gens s'approchent ici et
on appris que bien sûr il y a des
inquiétudes à travers le pays ils ont
entendu d'abord les strauss et ensuite
tous les chefs de partis parler de leurs
inquiétudes ils ont sans doute vu la bbc
en
sur toutes les chaînes
la chaîne de news avec leurs
présentateurs comme disait tout à
l'heure
lalonde et des invités sur le plateau en
habits sombres et cela en dit très long
qui serait la dernière fois qu'on a vu
les aigles qui se prépare tout à fait on
la dernière fois que qu'on a vu des
présentateurs de la bbc avec une cravate
noire c'était pour la le décès du prince
philippe il ya un an un peu plus d'un an
maintenant et on sait très bien que cela
a beaucoup
perturbé la reine la perte de son époux
a été un choc monumental et on s'attend
effectivement à ce que depuis ce moment
là l'état de santé de la reine n'a cessé
de diminuer jusqu'à sa mobilité perdu au
moment du jubilé ici où elle n'a pas pu
être dans le carrosse royal d'être au
coeur de ces cérémonies pour ceux des 70
ans de de son règne de ces la
célébration de son règne et c'était là
dieu officielle de la reine sans doute
en adieux touchants qui a duré plusieurs
jours et la population toute entière a
pu dire au revoir au monarque à ce
moment là et bien évidemment tout ce qui
est qui désormais on
peuvent venir essayer vont sans doute sa
masse est comme c'est le cas c'est la
tradition c'était la tradition pour la
mort de diana la tradition pour la mort
de philippe et maintenant évidemment
tout le monde attend une annonce
officielle qui sera sans doute une
annonce plus de ceux de la pianiste hop
ça vous étonne pas cette foule qui
s'amasse peu à peu devant buckingham
palace et la tradition elle est très
populaire la reine elizabeth 2 elle est
très populaire elle a traversé des
périodes de où elles avaient moins la
cote mais aujourd'hui elle est très
populaire et comme on explique cette
popularité alors que ça fait soixante
dix ans qu'elle est reine mais justement
c'est la constance c'est la constance
elle incarne une sorte de comme on dit
en français une sorte flegme britannique
qui plaît beaucoup aux gens surtout en
sachant que nous avons traversées déjà
des ddd ton un peu difficile et qu'on va
ont traversé de nouveau c'est vraiment
cet exemple-là qui plaît aux gens et les
gens sont attachés à la reine parce
qu'elle incarne une sorte d'idéal
spécifiquement britannique peut-être mes
amis des ateliers elizabeth ii incarne
cet idéal et pourquoi et bien parce que
elle a trouvé la juste mesure entre le
stoïcisme et l'empathie et ça se prend
un équilibre est très rare très rare
pratiquement inconnu chez les politiques
pas souvent le cas chez les rois et les
reines mais elle est là sur le trouver
est ce que son successeur s'il ya un
successeur un jour saura le faire je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas elle
est là le secret magique le secret
magique kevin guyot vous êtes j'espère
que la liaison rétablie avec vous êtes
d'accord avec ce que vient de dire james
dobbs
dans le sens où aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment à la récompense lorsque l'on
pense justement à la reine il ya
plusieurs généraux qui a pu y avait
énormément mais pourtant quand on pense
à la récompense à la d2 c'est pas pour
rien c'est parce qu'elle ferait vraiment
partie de notre quotidien elle fait
partie oncle et elle représente le passé
le aussi le présent du royaume uni de
l'histoire européenne et de l'histoire
du monde agnès poirier vous étiez bien
sûr je crois à londres lorsque elle a
reçu la toute nouvelle première ministre
qu'elle a officialisé sa nomination ali
strauss était mardi mais lisse trop
s'étaler à balmoral donc en écosse donc
les montres on vient d'apprendre qu'elle
est morte me dit philip toone à
l'instant donc en direct sur france 24
on viendra compliquer de sky news que
vous faites une actualité de sky news
pour le moment c'est ce que vous dites
philip wee attendait garde ça donc
ça provient donc en fait pour l'instant
c'est selon les médias philippe est faux
bien fouet c'est violer nos confrères
l'acquis qui indique que la reine
elizabeth ii est décédé à l'âge de 90
ans cette saison d'après bas clients
palace donc c'est uniquement un média
qu'il annonce un philip earl soyez juste
précis quel est le média qui l'annoncent
c'est sky news qui cite baqem palace
donc là la résidence à la reine devant
laquelle tu te sers foulée et amassé
donc donc voilà il faut rester prudent
puisque sa part été confirmée par
d'autres médias pour le moment donc
voilà je suis en train justement de
regarder un le fil afp un comme on dit
les agences de kings and queens oui mais
pour l'instant ce qu'on apprend c'est
que pour le moment toute la famille est
toujours à ballmer ont baissé de ta
fille oui viennent c'est officiel à
l'instant c'est ce que vous nous dites
agnès poirier qui est à londres c'est
officiel donc la reine est morte à l'âge
de 96 ans agnès poirier
c'est intéressant parce que c'était en
fait cet après midi
et c'est bien ce que beaucoup d'entre
nous pensions quand nous avons vu cet
après midi des présentateurs de la bbc
qui était en noir en blanc noir mais à
partir du moment où le souverain est
mort et certains d'entre eux étaient
très émus et dont on sait on s'est tous
dit ils savent quelque chose que nous ne
savons pas comme je vous avais dit
une demi heure voilà hervé renard
vous êtes toujours devant buckingham
palace et j'imagine qu'il doit y avoir
des réactions ce soir on vient
d'apprendre donc la mort de la reine
c'est officiel c'est un communiqué de
buckingham palace maintenant qui le dit
oui absolument et c'est tout le monde
tous mes collègues tout le monde y est
bien sûr une un mot à un moment de qui a
on s'attendait bien sûr à ce que à cette
annonce on sent des attentes qu'on
s'attendait peut-être peut-être parce
que l'annoncent revienne aussi vite en
attendant derrière moi vous allez voir
maintenant les gens qui vont
s'agglutiner devant buckingham palace et
il ya de plus en plus de gens qui
viennent ce sera sans doute une soirée
difficile une soirée où les gens vont
venir rendre hommage et puis maintenant
tout tout l'étiquette bat mettre en
place tout ce qui est prévu pour là
c'est parce qu'on
vous a perdu hervé jérémy stubbs donc
voilà on l'a appris la reine est morte
c'est vrai que c'est presque un choc
pour nous aussi parce que ça fait
plusieurs heures qu'on l'attendait là il
ya tout un protocole qui va se mettre en
place racontez-nous déjà les drapeaux en
berne ça ça ils vont être en berne à
travers le pays toute une journée que ce
qui va se passer là au royaume uni eh
bien il va falloir que on parle n'est ce
pas des deux corps derouard le corps
matériel corps symbolique donc le corps
de la reine est mort en écosse mais il
faut que ce corps soit transporté
en train jusqu'à londres
avec des arrêts y nombre sur le chemin
ensuite il y en une période où le corps
sera exposé et les personnes pour ans
défilé devant et ça va durer combien de
temps où ça va durer et je pense neuf
jours oui c'est un protocole qui est un
protocole
chaillet devient donc le grand sa
succession il devient donc roi
d'angleterre la succession est
automatique un teckel arin décède c'est
son fils charles qui devient
automatiquement le roi c'est pourquoi on
dit la reine et monte longue vie au roi
parce que c'est la succession est
immédiat il n'y a pas de deux breaks
contre l'entrée un monarque et son
successeur ça prend un point deuxième
point c'est que là tout un protocole qui
va rentrer en jeu à portée de tout de
suite il va y avoir une période on va
payer tous les drapeaux sont les
monuments déjà l'immense et voilà il
faut informer tous les chefs de
gouvernement le premier ministre les
chefs d'état du monde les chefs du tad
états du commonwealth tout le monde doit
être informé en regardant général canada
qui s'étaient envolés en avant qu'ils
puissent prendre les dispositions
nécessaires soit pour venir le monde
pour pour informer les gens qui sont des
plus proches après cela normalement le
prince charles doit prendre la parole
assez rapidement après le décès de sa
mère et à partir de demain voir comment
ces dix jours de
préparation pour cette cet enterrement à
savoir que la reine est ton décédé à
balmont son cercueil sera transporté à
londres par le train où elle sera mis
dans le palais de westminster c'est le
siège du gouvernement britannique où il
y aura une période de deuil où le public
va pouvoir passer de 25 de 10 jours
c'est jean-philippe pour pour
montrer leur respect et leur mais romain
simon à la reine on switch pour le
dernier jour de sa queue sur la
transporter au parler de haut à l'abbaye
de westminster qui juste à côté du
palais de westminster pour la cérémonie
des obsèques et ensuite ça on tirait à
côté son mari au château de windsor
kevin guyot vous peut-être réagir
justement vous qui êtes l'historien de
ce plateau
oui je suis désolé que je suis un petit
peu un petit peu ému de tout ça et il
est en train de faire du coup mes
publications pour annoncer la mort de la
reine à tous ceux qui vous suivent
effectivement je suis je suis très ému
je suis
on attendait forcément la mort de la
reine c'est un fait elle a 80 elle avait
96 ans lé théâtre et vit on l'a dit on
l'a vu pendant les 10 de la dernière
photo qu'on a pu voir des loges où elle
a donc elle recevait sa nouvelle
première ministre donc la quinzième de
son règne un record donc effectivement
c'était un c'était vraiment un
[Musique]
c'était vous voulez un flambeau qui a pu
nous emmener pendant que ses 70 ans et
qui nous quitte aujourd'hui qui qui va
présenter l'histoire comme je disais eu
autant que le présent parce que c'est
une souveraine qui a su moderniser la
monarchie pour en faire une institution
reconnue remarquable et incontournable
pour le royaume uni ou zorbit personnes
quasiment personne ou janvier
au royaume uni ben il va contredire le
fait que le royaume uni doit rester une
monarchie
même si on ne sait pas on ne savait pas
jusque là si le prince charles avait
vraiment prendre sa succession même si
certains allaient vrai allait aller se
poser la question si le prince charles
avait vraiment prendre la succession à
la tête du prince williams alors que
tout était tikrit vous savez très bien
depuis le départ salle et le prince
charles parce que sa petite fille dans
la course c'est écrit dans la cua oui
kevin guillon on a il ya toujours un
petit poème de sang avec vous j'ai
l'impression qu'il va disparaître au fur
et à mesure on sent votre votre émotion
on dirait me stoppe donc là aujourd'hui
femme maintenant au moment où on se
parle on peut dire que c'est donc
charles qui est le roi d'angleterre
comme on dit en france en tout cas c'est
du royaume le roi d'angleterre
roy décosse est en fait pour le moment
au roi de des relents du nord c'est tout
l'enjeu et pays gallo oui il était
prince du pays de galles maintenant il
est élégant
et ce à la continuité dont parlait kévin
guillot oui elle est automatique oui
tout à fait tout à fait à moins que dans
les jours à venir il n'annonce que il
décide d'appliquer mais c'est peu
probable à mon avis il a attendu très
longtemps
pour
prendre ce poste en quelque sorte et on
sait qu'ils n'attendaient que ça parce
que c'est quelqu'un qui est les
différents de la reine dans la mesure où
il a des idées politiques et sociales
qui ne craint pas d'exprimer de temps en
temps
d'une façon qui est qui n'est pas
vraiment dans la tradition établie par
elizabeth 2 alors là il y aura un
changement peut-être la lecture en
question c'est est-ce qui va se prendre
le modèle de sa mère et changer
complètement ou est-ce qu'il va essayer
de rester un peu lui même est de
continuer à intervenir à faire des
déclarations par exemple sur l'écologie
ainsi de suite c'est ça la grande
question
agnès poirier alors oui on voit cette
image voilà vous pouvez philippe taris
de sol et gris de marque impala stomp je
parlais tout à l'heure qui annoncent le
décès de la reine on a eu la même chose
en 1952
alors du décès de georges de 6,6 la
confirmation de la du décès de la marche
est donc la succession au printemps tout
est très formel au parquet un palace
c'est l'un des gros problèmes qu'a eue
le prince philippe canton la reine est
arrivée sur le trône en 1952 à savoir
qu'il trouvait que cette maison n'avait
pas bougé depuis des centaines d'années
que il fallait pour passer un message
donné le message à un valet qu elle est
transportée sur un plateau en argent à
l'autre bout du palais attendre le
message de retour et m'a dit mais je
prends le téléphone non non c'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe donc c'est très
difficile pour faire bouger les coutumes
sont menées à deux centenaires de cette
maison est là l'annnonce du décès de
l'abbé 2 et postés sont les grilles
comme ça toujours été le cas depuis
depuis des années et donc c'est quelque
part en quelque sorte annonce officielle
si ça vienne de berchem palach c'est à
dire qu'il n'y a pas de doute à avoir la
reine est bien décédé porte parole de la
maison blanche et nos pensées vont à la
famille au peuple du royaume uni
également une réaction de john madden
l'ancien premier ministre qui a lui
aussi donc ça lui
7,7 freiner ses 70 ans de règne agnès
poirier parce qu'on parle effectivement
du prince charles qui devient donc le
tout nouveau monarque aujourd'hui le roi
charles peut-être des modifications
qu'il va faire au sein de cette
monarchie où il fut juste lisible c'est
une correction c'est cette annonce alors
puis c'est la première fois que ça
arrive n'ai pas posté sur les grilles de
baqem palace en fait ces possessions les
grilles du château de balmoral là où la
reine est décédé que wade est rien on
voit donc cessons donc ce sont 17 une
image en écosse alors c'est le château
de balmoral que l'on voit donc
rectification un parti où la reine est
décédé donc c'est là où ils ont posté
l'annoncent voilà son chaton en écosse
où elle était où elles passent l'été on
sait ça et où donc est bien elle est
décédée
il ya quelques instants maintenant et
donc ce communiqué de buckingham palace
mais en fête au château de balmoral donc
agnès poirier oui peut-être qu'il va y
avoir des changements avec justement
charles ce que disais à l'instant jeremy
stubbs en tout cas il ya ses 70 ans de
règne qui sont qui reste exceptionnel et
c'est cela aujourd'hui que qui reste en
fête de la reine elizabeth 2
alors oui mais souvenez vous aussi que
victorien avait aussi régné très très
longtemps est finalement il y a un peu
de victoria chez la reine elizabeth et
il ya ce sens du devoir parce que tu
rémy par les deux à la fois l'empathie
mais qu'elle a eue depuis je dirais
seulement depuis la mort de la princesse
diana puisque tony blair lui avait rendu
un énorme service en lui disant écoutez
là il va falloir nous sommes dans une
autre ère d'émotion il faut que vous
montrez votre émotion à votre peuple ce
qu'elle avait réussi à faire et depuis
elle avait réussi à montrer cette
empathie
et donc donc ce qu'on gardera d'elle
c'est ce sens du devoir chevillée au
corps cette constance effectivement et
puis la longévité alors c'est une
peut-être ses plus grandes qualités
finalement et alors on a oublié de dire
que qu'est ce qui va se passer tout de
suite
lise traces la première ministre va
faire une un discours massage s'adresser
à la nation
devant dan street et ensuite c'est le
roi charles alors est ce qu il m'apprend
d'ailleurs question intéressante est ce
qu'il va prendre maintenant de charme à
ce moment là elle ce sera le roi charles
iii
ou va-t-il prendre le nom ce qu'il peut
faire apprendre un de ces prénoms comme
georges par exemple qui est le nom de
son grand-père va-t-il à être roi
georges on ne saura très vite et ensuite
donc après les profs et bien c'est le
roi charles
qui va s'adresser à la nation et ça
normalement c'était d'après le protocole
décidé depuis plusieurs années c'est à
18 heures le jour
delà de la mort du souverain mais comme
en grande bretagne les 18h48 ce sera
peut-être soit plus tard soit demain
philips est important ce choix du nom du
roi charles
ix c'est le genre le premier a été
exécuté les deux champs etc sur deux est
un roi qui qui part très bien vu dans
les yeux des britanniques dont peut-être
pour charles il aura envie de changer de
nom pour devenir pour pas être connue
sous un autre nom de roy jeu
personnellement je pense qu'il va garder
son prénom parce qu'on a toujours connu
comme chiant quand le prince jean et
c'est donc ce serait quand même bizarre
après toutes ces années la tonte de
tout d'un coup
avoir ouaki et charles mais qui ne
s'appelle plus cher s'il avait peut-être
25 ans 30 ans où il était beaucoup plus
jeune il fait peut-être changerait de
nom mais vous ne pensez pas qu'il a
priori il va rester ce penseur mais par
contre ce qui est important à savoir
c'est que il y avait beaucoup de
questions qui étaient posées depuis
longtemps son os que ses charmes qui va
succéder à sa mère ou est-ce que ça va
être directement passé à william est ici
oui comment ça peut se passer ça se fait
pas comme ça cela l'école il ya une
ligne de succession donc après la reine
c'est son fils aîné donc gens qui lui
succède ce qui le cas aujourd'hui
personne ne peut le pousser à la porte
c'est pas le gouvernement sur le premier
ministre ya deux façons de faire la
première c'est que y décide qui n'a pas
envie de le faire on verra bien où il
meurt avant sa mère donc ça c'est pas le
cas donc c'est normal que françois roy
quoi qu'il en soit maintenant kiliwa il
va pas et 3 pendant des décennies comme
sa mère il est déjà un monsieur d'un
certain âge il a 74 ans cette année donc
inapte à 70 ans de règne devant lui la
la
je pense que on voit on va voir une
reine de 10 15 20 ans au maximum et
quand on compare la situation actuelle
il ya un précédent qui était la reine
victoria qui a régné de 1837 1901
il son fils lui a succédé et doit set et
elle doit cette araignée pour montrer
peu tendre neuf ans mais il a quand même
marqué son époque avec énormément de
changements dans la monarchie long à la
société britannique il se peut que
chienlit et ont envie de faire toujours
la même chose donc dans un temps plus
court dire et misters c'est à dire que
le roi charles pourrait faire des
modifications au sein de cette monarchie
c'est fort probable une opportunité
peut-être pour lui est ce que c'est un
désir il s'est toujours présenté comme
quelqu'un qui modernise et il a besoin
de quitter l'ombre de sa mère donc il va
essayer quand même de garder un sens de
la tradition parce qu'il sait que sa
mère a été très populaire donc il ne va
pas en quelque sorte
s'affranchir de ça mais en même temps il
veut exister enfin on est pour lui même
donc il va faire des choses d'une
manière différente c'est certain le 4
juin 1953 en fait quelques mois après
qu'elle soit arrivée qu'elle a accédé au
trône puisque c'était en 1952 elizabeth
2 c a prononcé ces quelques mots que je
voudrais vous faire écouter
je déclare devant vous tous que je
consacrerai toute ma vie qu'elle soit
longue ou courte
à votre service et au service de la
grande famille impériale à laquelle nous
appartenons
c'est 1948 me dit à philippe stern est
effectivement c'était en afrique du sud
l'obs et 20e 47 d'abord elle avait fait
ce discours porté à que que sa vie soit
longue ou courte elle ça toujours au
service du dijon et du peuple mais
toujours au service des gens et du
peuple britannique c'est ce qui reste
tout de même d'elisabeth de jeremy
stubbs annoncent qu'elles viennent dire
la face qu'on ce discours de 1900 donc
47 oui c'est une vie de deux services
est en quelque sorte c'est curieux parce
que le prince charles en tant que prince
de galles à la devise est in je sers
mais jusqu'à présent c'est vraiment sa
mère qui a été
exemplaire à cet égard et lui il aura du
mal à mon avis à l'égaler années galères
envoie cette foule à l'acquis vraiment
commence à s'amasser devant buckingham
palace en ce sont des images en direct
tous et britanniques qui veulent rendre
hommage à la reine à la reine elizabeth
ii je ne sais pas si vous voyez ces
images agnès poirier vous qui êtes à
londres mais c'est vrai que ça commence
à être impressionnant cet hommage
globale ce qui va rester véritablement
ce sont ces soixante dix ans de règne
oui alors en fait ce qui va rester mais
ce que nous avons perdu quand même c'est
un lien le lien vivant avec
la guerre et avec le la reconstruction
d'après-guerre et avec le consensus
est ce
le consensus d'après guerre on était
dans un coma et qui est formidable voilà
qui est fort mise à mal aujourd'hui
est donc peut-être que ça va rendre ce
monde là où du moins l'héritage que nous
avons de la concorde d'après-guerre plus
vulnérables encore emmanuel macron tca
rend hommage sur twitter à la reine
elizabeth ii ami de la france dit-il les
hommages se multiplient le premier
ministre irlandais donc il parle
également d'une amie et puis john maggio
je vous le disais l'ancien premier
ministre britannique et lui rend hommage
le premier ministre italien également
donc qui parle justement de cet esprit
de service et qui avait justement la
reine elizabeth ii dont on vient de
parler kevin guyot c'est ça que vous
retiendrez vous de la reine elizabeth 2
cet esprit de service qu'elle a eue
pendant 70 ans de règne
bon c'est là vraiment d'eric toute sa
vie au royaume uni brook et elle est
devenue rennais 26 à 26 ans on est
extrêmement jeune on apporte comme
ambition de devenir et notre formulaire
et disquettes voulait à la base à se
pendre à cette époque là c'était faire
sa vie en tant que femme d'officiers
parce que la pratique était un officier
de marine à ce moment là elle a des deux
enfants est ce qu'elle voulait cette
esthétique sa famille et finalement la
santé de super à rattraper face côté
kévin guillot je vous interromps à
nouveau parce qu'on on vous entend vous
entends très mal le premier ministre
indien
qui qui narrait drame audi donc inquiets
en fait peiné il le dit par la mort de
la reine philippe tort il faut parler de
ces pays du commonweath l'inde
d'ailleurs fait partie des pays
fondateurs
ddd pays du commonwealth est ce que ça
va changer les choses parce qu'en fait
c'était compliqué de faire en sorte que
ces pays restent au sein de cette
communauté j'ai
dans une nouvelle ère et une nouvelle
période pour le commonwealth parce que
la reine et on était reine pendant
soixante dix on l a vu le démantèlement
de l'empiré britannique et légion en
train de démontrer quand elle et elle
est devenue reine en 1952 mais là à la
vue la fin de l'empiré britannique et la
création du com - depuis 1961 il y en a
cinquante six pays qui en sont membres
aujourd'hui je pense que
alors que la reine reste chef d'état
d'une partie de ces pays saisie me
semble il va y avoir certains pays qui
vont demander maintenant à couper le
courant à s'émanciper
donc c'est d'abord à l'australie à la
nouvelle zélande au canada et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui à cause cette ce lien
avec ce personnage historique depuis
tellement longtemps ces pays là on dit
nous resterons avec et les abeilles
comme chef d'état mais le jour elle
disparaît là on va faire le nécessaire
pour couper le cordon et donc je pense
qu'on peut voir maintenant un maton à
voir que certains pays vander nous
voulons plus que la famille wall
britannique soit un autre chef d'état
tiens mais ça faisait d'accord donc il
ya un risque à tout de même que ça
tangue un peu du côté de tous ces pays
d'où un risque mais
en ce qui concerne le commonwealth ce
qui est probable c'est que les pays
membres décident désormais d'élire un
des leurs comme en quelque sorte chef à
la place du monarque britannique
ce ne sera pas exactement une sorte de
révolte mais ce sera et on peut dire une
sorte république utilisation en quelque
sorte du com - off est-ce que ça risque
de changer également philippe l'unité du
royaume uni par conseil que l'ecosse a
peut-être des velléités d'indépendance
est ce que la reine elizabeth ii avait
vraiment jouer ce rôle et aujourd'hui il
va y avoir une sorte de fragilité plus
fort
oui non je pense que lui dément la mort
d'elizabeth ii ne va pas aider les
choses dans le bon sens mais vous savez
même s'il a les corses avaient demandé
l'indépendance et avait gagné le
référendum sur l'indépendance et même si
un autre référendum ce que les cold
stone la premier ministre écossaise
aimerait bien organiser
le charles restera toujours roi des
causses et est roi d'angleterre mais
c'est vrai que je pense qu ils lisent à
pet sont été un grand chagrin de voir le
pays
au royaume uni se disperser entre
plusieurs pays donc c'est quelque chose
au moins qu'elle ne verra pas qu'elle ne
verra pas mais dont vous ne l'exclus est
passé à vous en parlerez faire
impossible et c'est pas demain la veille
agnès poirier sur cette fragilité
justement de l'unité du royaume uni
connaît les prochaines heures et les
prochains jours
un soubresaut
de l'unionisme et avant sans doute la
fin de cette union au fait qui a été
vraiment mise à mal par le break site et
la reine c'était un petit peu comme
d'autres institutions comme l'armée
comme la bbc mais la bbc aussi est mise
à mal le ciment de ces quatre nations
qui composent le royaume uni et
ma foi nous avons arrêté un homme même
s'il est consultatif prévue dans un an
le 19 octobre 2000 24 en écosse si les
gosses
obtient peut-être laval validation
westminster pour ce référendum si il est
positive pour l'indépendance et bien que
peut-être la réunification der land est
à envisager
elle est certainement envisager les
sondages montrent que le sentiment
entre un sentiment favorable à cette
réunification existe même si elle n'est
pas encore majoritaire donc oui c'est la
fin d'une et alain philippe a tout à
fait raison c'est la fin d'une ère et
mais pour le moment ces prochaines
heures ces prochains jours ses premières
semaines en tout cas
jusqu'à la fin du protocole et de l'art
de la disparition du tout la pompe
autour de la séparation de la reine et
bien vous pouvez vous attendre au
contraire un espèce de d'une union union
sacrée mais qu'il ne fera pas
tiens misters union sacrée en tout cas
pour les quelques jours qui vont venir
puisque le royaume-uni est en deuil et
ça va être un deuil national et ça va
durer plusieurs jours c'est ce que nous
expliquait philippe oui oui bien sûr
bien sûr il y aura une très grande
émotion peut-être encore plus que pour
la princesse diana c'est à voir mais ce
qui est certain pour l'instant c'est que
la reine est morte mais pas la monarchie
la monarchie continue et ce serait un
peu hâtif de vouloir y mettre fin déjà
un nous verrons ce que nous verrons dans
les années à venir hier beaucoup
d'émissions philippe non ça c'est
certain on perd un personnage qui est un
lien historique que nous avons toujours
connu qu'on a quand même vraiment
considérer un peu comme leur deuxième
maman quelque part parce qu'elle a
toujours été présent et il monde comme
je peux changer depuis 1952 on sortait
de la guerre et y avait encore des
rationnements l'a vu elle arrive la
télévision et les billons couleur donc
qui marchent aulas lui les réseaux
sociaux le mariage gay tout ça s'est
passé pendant la reine elizabeth ii une
inconnue tous les chefs d'état de pays
on retient vincent auriol en france elle
a vu kato chef d'état américain c'est un
personnage énorme qui ne quittent
aujourd'hui donc il faut tout
reconstruire mais la monarchie et les
vrais continue j'ai confié aux emprunts
chiant pour relever le défi ça fait
quand même 60 disons qu'il attend ce
jour donc s'ils n'arrivent pas à fait
quelque chose de bien eh bien ça
m'étonnerait donc c'est vrai qu'on va y
avoir il va y avoir beaucoup d'émotion
parce que c'est un personnage tellement
or n'ont tellement énorme que ça ne
pourrait pas être autrement merci
beaucoup en tout cas assez effectivement
une époque la fin d'une époque et donc
le royaume uni en deuil puisque donc la
reine elizabeth est décédée à 96 ans
donc après 70 ans de règne merci
beaucoup philippe recteur la merci
jérémy stubbs merci agnès poirier merci
cabinda guyot et puis merci bien sûr à
hervé hervé amériques est toujours notre
correspondant à londres on va revenir en
images pour terminer justement ce débat
sur les 70 ans de règne de la reine
elizabeth
donc en images
pour célébrer ses 90 ans elle arborait
comme à son habitude une tenue et un
chapeau aux couleurs assorties et
l'image reconnaissable entre tous est
devenue iconique
né en 1926 elle n'était pourtant pas
destiné à devenir souveraine mais dix
ans plus tard quand son oncle edouard 8
renonce au trot de par amour c'est le
père d'elizabeth georges 6 qui devient
bon
pour de crise d'ambulances pour l'armée
britannique pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale elisabeth assume pleinement son
rôle de princesse héritière
[Musique]
est enfermé tout écrit en blanc
et sa vie fut longue le plus long règne
de l'histoire de la monarchie
britannique
le 9 septembre 2015 elisabeth pas le
record établi par sa trisaïeule la reine
victoria
la mort subite de son père en 1952 place
elisabeth sur le trône elle n'a alors
que 25 ans son couronnement est suivi
par plus de 20 millions de personnes
[Musique]
au sacre succèdent alors des temps
bouleversée pour la reine l'empiré
britannique se meurent les unes après
les autres les anciennes colonies
prennent leur indépendance
c'est le temps du commonwealth
au royaume uni c'est l'époque des
swinging sixties et de la remise en
cause de la monarchie les enfants
d'elisabeth après des histoires de conte
de fées divorce les uns après les autres
et voilà le clan royal qui vacille
en 1997 c'est une tragédie qui ébranle
la couronne la mort de la princesse
diana plongé le royaume dans un deuil
immense la reine elle se mure dans le
silence une réaction qui affecte
profondément ces sujets
elisabeth mettra une semaine avant
d'ordonner la mise en berne des drapeaux
celle qui a pour devise de ne jamais se
justifier ni se plaindre devra
s'expliquer à la télévision
[Musique]
avec le temps la reine retrouve sa
popularité
les mariages princiers kate et william
megan et harry et les naissances des
arrières petits enfants redonne des
couleurs à une monarchie vieillissante
en 2012 le jubilé qui consacre ses 60
ans de règne est suivi par des dizaines
de milliers de personnes elizabeth ii a
toujours refusé d'abdiquer elle gardera
dans la mémoire de ces sujets l'image
d'une femme de caractère qui a voulu
toute sa vie préservé la royauté
[Musique]